in the last lesson I proposed that the
nouns cases and the thematic roles of
arguments might be two different things
now I'd like to illustrate that
distinction with some examples and make
this really clear as we move on to
considering alignment let's look at some
sentences in Catalan a language spoken
in eastern Spain and some sentences in
Basque which is a completely separate
language spoken in northern Spain in
Basque the sentence eunuch de we qu
salut means John has seen Peter the
sentence baiu keone gu salut means Peter
has seen John we'll translate those
sentences into Catalan as an John Bevere
para and imbed above Lu Lu Shuang in all
of those sentences we can see that the
subject and the object are clearly
marked they're distinct this is
something we'd expect but something
different happens when we look at
intransitive verbs in the two languages
in Basque let's use the example Gennaro
Rita
and in Catalan the parallel example in
Schwann baccarat both of these sentences
mean John fell in English in Catalan the
subject of this sentence works exactly
like the subject of the transitive
sentence in Basque it works exactly like
the object of the transitive sentence
this supports the idea I put forth
earlier which is that cases and roles
are treated as distinct if we look at
the roles of those sentences with the
verb see we have an agent and a patient
with the verb fell we have an
experiencer in Catalan the agent and the
experiencer role are treated identically
they're filled with a noun in the same
case while the patient role is filled
with a different case in Basque the
agent role is filled with a different
case than the patient and the
experiencer roles we end up with noun
roles filled with nouns from different
cases in different languages of course
there are names for these two alignments
the first gets called nominative
accusative and the second is her give
absolutive and these aren't the only
ways languages have of handling
alignment either
I hope you've been able to strengthen
your understanding of grammar take the
time to review my other linguistics
lessons and subscribe to learn some
interesting stuff about language thanks
for learning with me